alors Geneviève toujours dans le coup
pour l'instant
faites vos courses sur le net Geneviève
oh non j'y vais tout doucement lentement
mais sûrement mais vous adorez le 10 de
Charlotte Gainsbourg oui moi j'aime bien
sûr
je suis dans une voiture il y a un lion
devant et des Lionnes dedans
vous êtes vous êtes très branché vous
avez laissé tomber le jean taille basse
Geneviève j'arrive jamais mis porter des
strings
c'est fini ah ouais c'est fini c'est
quoi maintenant le Petit Bateau presque
oui presque c'est le petit boxeur short
alors 2 mois après vous la trouvez
comment cette Miss France 2016 là très
bien est-ce qu'elle dit bien merci quand
on lui donne une tranche de saucisson
on va lui remettre ça 307 justement elle
va avoir une 307
alors quand tu as eu l'élection de Miss
France là c'est une qui a fait exprès
d'être sourds pour pas répondre aux
questions de Jean-Pierre Foucault
c'est une fille qui est très bien et je
pense que ça a été une expérience
formidable et on a énormément de
demandes
et cette rumeur là sur le comité
on dit que c'est un réseau de call-girls
sérieusement on fait quoi après mais ça
dépend dans toutes les directions il y a
pas de multi il y a pas de moules Miss
France
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on va faire un Miss quiz alors attention
attention Geneviève concentrez-vous là
quelle Miss France elle finit dans un
film érotique pour M6 intitulé La Veuve
Noire
je sais pas bon
en 19 junior Nathalie Marquay
elle aime bien caché hein
alors mais là quelle Miss France a fini
princesse Begum agaçant
quelle Miss France avait des tendances
nymphomanes
elle a voulu faire un procès mais
tu nous regardes
[Rires]
bon ah attention quel Miss France
n'aimait pas le ton en boîte ça fait
tellement
elle a écrit dans un livre d'ailleurs ça
vous a fait de la peine et à moi aussi
ouais
une boîte de thon pour une personne
quand je l'invite quelle Miss France a
fini par présenter Fort Boyard et le
téléachat ah bah si c'est
la fille de Dannick pâtisson
[Musique]
quelle Miss France a fini par épouser
Jean-Pierre Mocky
c'est
Patricia
barzicaine
de Miss une très belle fille d'origine
polonaise
quelle Miss France a été soupçonnée
d'être un homme c'était Élodie mais non
mais je suis parti là-bas avec toute
l'équipe de Thomas Hugues pour aller la
défendre quelle Miss France a fini muse
de Jean-Charles de
Laetitia Bléger
par cette bonne femme tu as vu les
photos
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu